appear sensor after doubling down on his
rejection of a two-state solution and
pandering to hardliners in his party as
Israeli Prime Minister Netanyahu given
up on peace and should the rest of the
world give up on the two-state solution
as long as he remains in power Jord man
to debate this is the author of the war
on the west Murray and the Palestinian
national initiative leader Mustafa bouti
Mr bouti let me start with you your
reaction to my interview there with Mark
regev well my reaction is that Mr RV
speaks about Palestinians have to give
up give up what I don't understand and
he wants uh peace he wants security
without ending the Israeli occupation he
ignores the basic facts which is that
Israel has conducted ethnic cleansing
against 70% of the Palestinian people
forcing them to become refugees and is
depriving them from coming home for all
these 75 years second is ignoring that
Israel is conducting the longest
occupation in modern history 56 six
years of occupation of West Bank and
Gaza he's ignoring the fact that we are
all suppressed by Israel not only in
Gaza but also in the West Bank we are
being killed in the West Bank we are
being killed in the Gaza Strip he speak
he he speaks about the that the numbers
of of victims is incorrect I mean this
is very silly because I think the health
Ministry has issued the names of
everybody that is killed with their ID
numbers and their age and everything
so unfortunately
unfortunately what we've heard is the
same thing that Israel has been doing
for all the last 75 years repeating the
same thing and expecting different
results A very wise Jewish
Man by the name of Albert Einstein said
some he said something very wise he said
it is absolutely in it is insanity to
keep repeating the same thing and expect
different results well actually is
actually I can tell you he didn't
actually say that but it's a it's a
quote often ascribed to him but the
point is there Douglas Murray the point
is good okay I'll take the point he
didn't there's no record of him ever
saying it let let me ask you Douglas
about this you and I debated this a lot
you have a very firm position completely
uh behind Israel which I completely
understand there's anything that's going
on now in terms of the withdrawal of so
much support now from allies of Israel
does any of it give you pause for
thought about how this actually ends
because I'm not sure the Israeli
government knows how this ends and that
concerns
me well I think the Israeli government
knows better than most people certainly
most pundits about how it might end um I
think that there are several things I
have to say in reply to Mr barouti by
the way first of all when I was on this
show last with Mr baruti uh he said that
he hadn't said something he said and we
actually had to issue a a confirmation
on the program subsequently that he had
in fact said the words that he had
denied saying but that had come out of
his M mouth praising the so-called
Martyrs um let me say two other things
firstly on the question of the West Bank
frankly in Israel there are very few
people very few people in Israel who
believe that even if you can have a
two-state solution now is a good time to
talk about it I was in the knesset the
parliament earlier today and among other
people saw the head of the leftwing
opposition Mr leid he doesn't believe
this is a time to speak about a
two-state solution why because if you
gave a state to the Palestinians and
don't forget Israel did give a state to
the Palestinians in 2005 in the Gaza and
look what we got from it uh the world
got its money ransacked uh the Hamas
leaders making themselves fantastically
rich and then sending Rockets into
Israel so the first thing is even the
most left-wing figures in Israeli
politics don't think this is a good time
to talk about the two-state solution
because among other things it would
suggest that there was a reward for the
terrorists of October the 7th and the
reward for the actions of that day was
to double down on giving the
Palestinians yet another state the
second thing that has to be said about
that if I may is on the subject of the
West Bank if you go to the West Bank as
I was again the other night and if you
stand in the Hills overlooking Israel
you will see from those Hills the lights
of Tel Aviv the city I'm standing in at
the moment you will see the lights of
hper and you'll see the lights of borian
airport now knowing what Israel knows
about what Hamas did with the Gaza
making it into a military infrastructure
and firing rockets at Southern and
Central Israel why on Earth would the
Israelis give another piece of territory
which they didn't have security over in
the West Bank to another Palestinian
faction which would have the ability to
fire similar rockets at every single
part of Israel and I need to add one
other thing quickly on the subject of
the Palestinian Authority many people
outside Israel seem to think that the
Palestinian Authority is as it were the
Peaceable wing of Hamas or it's a sort
of shin Fain to hamas's Ira that is not
the case the Palestinian Authority as
well as being a deeply corrupt entity
which I don't need to tell Mr barouti
about he knows well about that as well
as being a deeply corrupt entity the
Palestinian Authority that is funded by
the Israelis as well as the Europeans
the British and the rest of the
International Community pays salaries to
terrorists it pays salaries the people
who kill people in Israel and that is
something absolutely impossible to make
peace with Mr barouti use the word
disgusting so Mr barouti over to you it
is disgusting it is dis Mr govern Mr
Morgan I think you have to be fair you
can't bring Mark Riv and give him like
10 or 15 minutes and then bring another
pro-israeli and make him share the time
with me you have to be fair in giving me
enough time because what we've just
heard heard is absolutely rubbish
absolutely rubbish just repeating
Israeli propaganda just repeating faults
and and I don't agree with him that he
has verified what I said I don't agree
with him totally and he is repeating the
same aggressive and fascist speech they
don't want to States what do they want
to do with the 7 million people
Palestinian 7 million Palestinians live
on the land of historic Palestine equal
to the number of Jewish people what is
the solution they don't want two State
solution fine let's have one Democratic
state with equal rights for everybody
but no Netanyahu and his fascist
government he has fascist in his
government he has smotrich and Bing ver
who call themselves fascist these people
don't want to see a two-state solution
don't want to see one Democratic state
so their solution is exactly what they
are trying to do in Gaza now which is
genocide and ethnic cleansing genocide
it is genocide what's happening because
we are talking about 32,000 Palestinian
people killed including those under the
rebel and 64,000 people injured 63,000
people injured that is 4% of the
population if that had happened in the
United States of America you would be
talking about 12 million people killed
or injured is that acceptable okay is it
is it not that Israel is occupying the
West Bank isn't the United States of
America saying that there is occupation
theal says there is occupation I hear
you I'm going to go back to Douglas so
Afra muris the UK's Chief Rabbi has said
that using the word genocide to describe
Israel's actions in Gaza is an
increasingly frequent disingenuous Mis
appropriation of the term he said the
use of a term is a moral inversion which
undermines the memory of the worst
crimes in human history and designed to
tear open the still gaping wounds of the
Holocaust
oh Douglas we can't hear you I don't
know if you can hear me but we can't
hear
you there might be a sound I got you
back I
think okay
um let me just say can you hear me now P
yes I can hear you can you hear me now
let me just quickly say this about the
genocide thing of course that's the case
Mr barouti likes to throw around the
word fascist fine I'll throw it back at
you Mr barouti not just a fascist but an
apologist four terrorists fine we can
all throw around slurs at each other but
more important is the fact that you said
that I had told lies unlike you I don't
tell lies I'll tell you why I'll tell
you why unlike you unlike you I don't
speak out of two sides of my mouth I'm
speaking out of one side of my mouth and
it's direct at you so let me just
correct what you just said you said what
I said were lies unfortunately for you I
have here with me the amended
Palestinian prisoners law of 2004 now
mmud abas who now runs the Palestinian
Authority signed this into law this
means that and I'm quoting Article 2
here prisoners anyone incarcerated in
the occupations prisons for his
participation in the struggle against
the occupation will be given a salary by
by the let me finish my point will given
salary by the Palestinian Authority oh
you think they're Freedom Fighters well
let me tell you another couple of things
then because everyone watching pays
their taxes and some of their taxes go
to the Palestinian Authority here's the
budget the Palestinian Authority in 2018
this is the PA's own budget Mr barouti
so don't lie about that
$162 million was allocated to the
prisoners and released prisoners
Ministry in in in 2018 in 2018
approximately $193 million was given by
the PA to families of the martyrs there
is an increasing list depending on how
many Jews you've killed of the amount of
money you get is the Palestinian
Authority doing that or not Mr barouti
CU I have their budget in my hand okay
Mr barouti out of respect uh for
fairness answer that
question yeah but uh I I'm sure your
guest has to be a bit polite you can't
keep saying you can answer that one
question well I will answer it yes they
they support the prisoners families they
support as form of Social Security
support they support the I mean nobody
even if you consider even even even if
you consider somebody is is doing
something wrong you cannot punish his
children and his wife in an act of
collective punishment this is Sal the
people who do the terror as you well
know Mr you said something wrong also
Palestinian Authority really does not I
don't defend the Palestinian Authority
but I'm telling you 90% of the
Palestinian Authority budget comes from
taxpayers from Palestinian people and
only 10% comes from Israeli government
cont and contrary to no no no no and
Israel is p connect committing piracy
stealing our taxpayers money preventing
health educ health people from getting
their salar preventing the Palestinian
Authority from you you shut up please
let me answer can you shut up don't
interrupt me please well you don't I
will be interrupting you each time you
speak you shut up you are not the one
who is asking me the questions you're
not the anchor so shut up please and let
me answer I am saying what you are
to do here is to mislead the discussion
ask I I'm the main discussion here is is
there Israeli occupation of Palestinian
land or not if people are occupied what
does international law says
International says law say law says that
people who are under occupation have the
right to struggle against their
occupiers that's what the UN says you
can't deviate you can't deviate the
discussion and the the the main fact
here is that the problem we have is that
Israel is occupying Palestinian land and
Israel is oppressing Palestinian people
since 1967 Israel conducted 1 million
arrests against the 7 million people who
are living there how could this be
acceptable what we see here is
the just to be clear I am I am just to
be clear I Am The Anchor I Am The Anchor
and I'm now going to Douglas respond to
that
Douglas two things first of all Mr bti
talks about the
Israelis
Mr Mr
B
Mr mrti let Douglas Murray respond don't
talk over him yeah okay fine
Please Mr barouti doesn't want a
two-state solution because he doesn't
want a Jewish State he wants the river
to the sea to be a Palestinian State
ruled by him and his corrupt friends but
secondly he cannot answer the question
I've put to him repeatedly this is the
PA budget it rewards terrorism and let
me just finish Mr barouti since I
allowed you that right in the end this
budget not only extends to rewarding the
people who carry out acts of terrorism
against Jews and the families of people
who do thus incentivizing Terror and
that's the Palestinian Authority the
Palestinian Authority is also now the
Palestinian Authority has also now
committed to pay salaries to the
fighters and the terrorists of as from
October the 7th and their families so
tell me please peers or Mr barouti where
is the good negotiating partner on the
Palestinian side here exactly well I
tell you I tell you what I'm going to do
I'm going to wrap this by saying this I
don't think there is a good negotiating
party on either side I don't think you
can possibly have peace with Hamas still
in place I don't think we're going to
achieve peace with Benjamin Netanyahu in
charge of Israel uh and his Hardline
rightwing cabinet so if you want honest
view I think we need a completely clean
room of leadership um and that's the
only way is ever going to get resolved
but I appreciate you both for coming on
together and debating it passionately
thank you both for your time Mr barouti
Mr Murray I appreciate
it